ein weiterer punkt meine damen die haben
auch natürlich freiwillig im flugzeug
zusammen gesessen
ja also wir sind gemeinsam geflogen mit
dem risiko dass sie kannten
selbstverständlich kann man nicht
ausschließen dass im flugzeug irgendwer
sich auch anstieg der vertritt meine
maske aber das risiko hat sich dadurch
nicht erhöht dass sie in dieser sehr
großen halle zusammen geblieben sind
[Musik]
zusammen herforder ist der raum war
nicht eng
also im flugzeug dem sie sich freiwillig
heraus gesetzt haben was deutlich enger
ja also dieser raum war deutlich ist der
terminal d ist im freies terminal dafür
wer wer gemeinsam sich entschließt in
dieser zeit in ein flugzeug zu steigen
will komisch komisch panik machen
hinterher bei so einer situation zu
sagen er habe ein problem aber eine
klare haltung also das risiko entscheide
ich wenn ich ins flugzeug gehe erhöhe
ich persönlich mein risiko dafür mich zu
infizieren und die allgemeinheit hat ein
recht darauf auch vor einzelnen
verhalten geschützt zu werden
das ist der auftrag den wir haben wir
machen das ja nicht weil wir irgendwem
hier zu nahe treten wollen sondern weil
wir sicherstellen wollen dass nicht
irgendwelche anderen menschen infiziert
werden mit einem deutlich schwierigeren
virus und bei dieser abwägung die bei
jedem von uns jeden tag zur
einschränkung im moment führt die dazu
führt dass viele ihre familien überhaupt
nicht besuchen dürfen dass kinder nicht
zur schule geht können kinder ihre
freundin nicht besuchen dürfen ist
dieser teil einer reise anzutreten schon
mal eine besondere gefahr und da muss
sich jeder vorher im klaren sein wer in
diesen zeiten reist dass das etwas
schwieriger und komplizierter sein kann
als im normalfall
ich hoffe ich bin laut genug mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren